it becomes an incredible
three-dimensional film strip this is
mesmerizing how did he design a
structure that has this amazing artistic
property I just don't get it it's based
on an illusion called a zoetrope which
is something that was invented long
before the first films were made take a
series of steel frames
put them in a row flash it with a strobe
and say move past the eye and makes it
look like a moving picture artists
Akinori created this 3d printed piece of
acrylic with thin horizontal and
vertical strips the walkers outline is
actually hidden in each vertical slice
of that donut and each of those slices
is one frame of the animation but why do
we see all of these hidden images as an
animation this is a phenomenon called
apparent motion its motion that appears
to exist even though it doesn't really
exist so let's say there are two
flashing lights if the time between the
flashes is between 30 milliseconds and
300 milliseconds we perceive that as the
light jumping from one bulb to the other
and back again
I can already has used this principle to
set his creation in motion at just the
right speed so our brains think that
they're seeing the smooth movement of a
walker
Akinori has taken an ancient technique
and combined it with modern day
technology to create a beautiful piece
of art
you
you